je crois au bicamérisme qui garantit une
démocratie mieux équilibrée il n'est pas
de république forte sans institutions
puissantes nez de temps troublés nos
institutions sont résistantes aux crises
et aux turbulences
j'aurais sans doute reconnu monsieur le
premier ministre le discours d' emmanuel
macron président de la république au
congrès lors des mois de juillet 2017 et
2018 et il avait raison
nous connaissons une crise sociale une
crise culturelle une crise territoriales
mais nous ne connaissons pas de crise
des institutions pour autant dans sa
lettre aux français le président de la
république met en discussion la
transformation du sénat quelles sont vos
intentions à l'égard du sénat la parole
à monsieur le premier ministre monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice
vous avez cité le président de la
république dans son discours gré vous
auriez pu aussi même si c'est moins
prestigieux site et le premier ministre
à l'occasion du discours que j'ai
prononcé pour la première fois au sénat
je reconnais que ça a moins de prestige
mais mais vous mais vous reconnaîtrez
aussi madame la sénatrice que à
l'occasion de ce discours j'avais
indiqués mon attachement bicamérisme le
rôle essentiel dans une démocratie de ce
dialogue permanent entre deux assemblées
qui tirent leur légitimité de mode de
désignation différentes temporalités
différentes
c est un élément constitutif constitutif
de notre équilibre démocratique et
j'observe que ce n'est pas propre au
génie français même s'il est
considérable puisque dans toutes les
démocraties c'est ce dialogue qui permet
une forme de sagesse et des clips donc
je n'ai aucun problème madame la
sénatrice à dire aujourd'hui comme je
les ai toujours dit que j'étais attaché
et obliques améris mme et au sénat et
j'observe que et j'observe madame la
sénatrice que dire ceci ne doit pas je
pense que vous pourrez le reconnaître
avec moi nous exonérer d'une réflexion
sur le bon fonctionnement du bicamérisme
sûr
la bonne désignation de ceux qui siègent
dans ces deux instances sûr mais enfin
bien entendu vous avez cité le mouvement
des gilet jaune reconnaissait avec moi
que dans la très grande masse de
revendications qui sont exprimés dans
leur très grande diversité
il y a aussi des questionnements pas
forcément sur l'existence de telles ou
telles assemblées mais sur la capacité
de telle ou telle assemblée a
correctement représenté la population
française je ne dis pas madame la
sénatrice
je ne dis pas madame la sénatrice que
c'est les seules revendications mais
nous pouvons je crois reconnaître que
ces questions sont posées âme dans une
démocratie comme la nôtre
le président de la république dans le
débat qu'il a engagées a ouvert un
chapitre sur la démocratie et la
citoyenneté
posons des questions dans la démocratie
et la citoyenneté sur la participation
de nos concitoyens la prise de décision
que ce soit d'ailleurs au niveau local
ou au niveau national sur la
représentation de nos concitoyens sur le
fonctionnement de nos institutions
sur ce besoin de participation de nos
concitoyens il a souhaité faire en sorte
que le débat soit ouvert
le président du sénat a choisi à
l'occasion d'une conférence de presse
qui se tenait je crois ce matin monsieur
le président d'indiquer c'est lui
appartenait l'attachement rappelé par le
président de la république au
bicamérisme il n'y a pas de sujet là
dessus en revanche je serai toujours
ouverts à cette discussion qui est une
discussion qui doit être continu dans le
temps pour faire en sorte que nos
institutions fonctionnent mieux que
notre bicamérisme fonctionne mieux que
nos citoyens soient toujours convaincu
qu'il fonctionne comme il devrait
fonctionner c'est ça le sens du débat et
je crois que ce sont des questions très
raisonnable et qui intéressent nos
concitoyens
[Applaudissements]
j'entends votre réponse monsieur le
premier ministre nous sommes d'accord
sur le fait qu'il faille mener une
réflexion je rappelle d'ailleurs qu'elle
avait commencé dans les assemblées avant
de se dérouler sur les ronds-points et
qu'à aucun moment le sénat ne s'était
montré hostile à cette réflexion
mais puisque nous sommes en temps de
grands débats je vais pouvoir faire
aussi
si vous permettez quelques observations
d'abord pour rappeler qu'avant tout le
président de la république au terme de
notre constitution
il est garant garante des institutions
et sans doute devra-t-il résister à la
tentation de jeter ses institutions en
pâture au mécontentement de la
population pour précisément faire
changer d'objets à ce mécontentement
je rajouterai aussi que le président de
la république semble finalement beaucoup
s'inspirer du sénat désormais ces temps
derniers
j'en prendrai quelques exemples
lorsqu'il évoque le travail sur le
statut de l'élu lors de sa réunion
devant les maires de l'heure il parle du
rapport de nos collègues bockel dardot
lorsqu'il évoque l'évolution de la loi
notre le président la république parle
de la proposition de loi par retailleau
d'arnaud lorsqu'il évoque l'adaptation
locale de la limitation de vitesse à 80
km/heure il parle du rapport de nos
collègues raison vullien fichet
lorsqu'il évoque les objectifs annuels
en matière d'immigration dans sa lettre
aux français
le président de la république parle de
l'amendement récent notre collègue roger
karoutchi
lorsqu'il veut prendre des mesures
contre les capteurs conclure le
président de la république reprend la
proposition de loi du président
retailleau avant de songer à transformer
le sénat peut-être l'exécutif pour tulle
songer à transformer son regard sur le
sénat nous ne sommes pas qu un
contre-pouvoir encombrante
nous sommes aussi et avant tout la voix
des territoires de france
[Musique]
merci